all, let's go back to the phones at (617)
830-4750.
We will go first to our caller from the two
six seven area code.
Who's calling today from two six seven.
Oh, hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Okay.
Hey David.
Um, my name is Joel.
I'm from Philadelphia.
I just wanted it and yeah, I just wanted to
tell you like, um, I really appreciate what
you do and then like, um, to be honest with
you, like, you know, one of those videos of
like people saying like, oh, they were brainwashed
into thinking like the alright is like the
truth, the real truth and the left is bad,
etc.
Etc.
Yeah,
I was one of those people to be honest with
you.
Like this happened like I guess like a year
or two ago cause I was originally left-leaning.
But um, it's like rather Trump got elected.
I started watching like all these videos of
like, I don't know, just like people do, like
the being left leaning people and they're
like, they just get mad and stuff like that.
Hold on by like, who were you watching?
Who were you watching on the right that appealed
to you?
Uh, Info wars is one yet.
Yeah, it was the date people in like May and
then like they wouldn't make them seem like
super emotional, like crybabies yup.
You know?
And that, so that appealed to you on a, like
an emotional level?
Um, yeah, kind of.
I just didn't want to associate myself with
those kind of people, you know, because I
wanted to, I thought like I wanted to be more
mature, so I thought the Wright was way more
mature, you know?
Right.
But so he, I guess that's very interesting
because it shows us the importance of not
only making the right arguments but making
them in the right way.
But, so like you're saying, you were left
wing on policy like you were, I mean like
so what were some of the things you believed
before you were sucked in by, by Alex Jones?
Um, well I kinda, I kind of believe like,
like I was used support or like immigration,
you know, like I liked like, um, I didn't
really like believe in all the right wing
policies or like immigration.
I was just in majority like left.
Like I was in supportive like immigration
and all that stuff, bay base cause basically
that cause I didn't really know that much,
uh, about like politics and policies and all
of that.
So it doesn't sound like you were, it doesn't
correct me if I'm wrong, but it doesn't sound
like you were so much left wing as you were
sort of just not that involved in politics.
Is that fair to say?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That's fair.
Yeah, that's fair.
Because before I w I didn't really know that
much about policies and politics or whatever,
you know, but I was, but I was like four or
less lean presidents like Barack Obama and
stuff like that.
I wasn't like, I was for like the Democrats
cause like my family's my family, uh, as majority,
uh, left things.
So I would just like go with them.
But then like, um, uh, I would, but like I
would think like the media makes Trump like
out to be like a bad person when he's, when
he's not really then what's for Bedford?
That's why I was thinking before I told me
it was like stuff about him, but like that's
what they may be wanting to believe.
Cause I'll listen to people like mark dice
and like I felt and you know, I just thought
like this dude was like a lie.
He was speaking the truth and all that like
that.
But like I,
I was like such a pieces back then.
I'm not going to lie.
I feel like such a piece.
Okay.
And so every, every time, you swear, just
so you know, we've got to bleep you because
of the broadcast, but so you felt you felt
like a bad person.
I gotcha.
So you were watching info wars
and you were watching Marcus
dice and anything else you were watching in
particular?
Um, not, not really.
Not really.
Not that I can think of, but those were like
the main ones.
And like, I just felt like, I just felt like
I had a lack of empathy for most people.
Like I remember back when a hurt, like that
hurricane hit Puerto Rico, I was watching
a, it was like a interview, like this woman,
like grieving for her, like loss of her housing
and stuff like that.
And I fricken, I laugh, I laughed at it and
that's, you know, looking back and now I feel
like, you know, I'm a terrible person
now with peace and love.
I don't know that it does Alex Jones make
you not care about a hurricane victim that
quite frankly seems like it's related to other
things going on in one's life, don't you think?
Yeah.
I mean, I was just saying, I'm just saying
like I really, I really hated myself back
then.
Like, cause like people like you and counseling
see like y'all brought me back to like, you
know, having that hi Mo.
Like you know, those good morals and stuff
like that.
I cause like I even, I even told my, I didn't
try to tell my dad about it and my dad told
me he like that he said like, I don't even
know what I'm talking about, you know, and
looking back on it now, he was right.
Hmm.
Yeah, I'm understanding, I'm on, I'm understanding,
I think the circumstances.
Well listen, I'm glad that it sounds like
you're doing better now.
And it sounds like you had a lot going on
at the time.
I'm glad you're, you're not a, you know, subscribing
to info wars conspiracies anymore and uh,
best of luck.
All right, my friend.
Thank you David.
Okay.
Appreciate your phone call.
Thank you.